- But Joel, you've been working
with "Tiger King," right?
You've been interviewing all the people?
For Netflix, right?
- Yeah.
I'm holding on to the
coattails of that documentary.
They asked me to host the
wrap, the catch-up special
and see where everybody was
that was agreeing to be on camera.
And so, they asked me a
few days before it aired.
And we quickly scrambled together.
They had a bunch of people
ready to be interviewed.
So I had barely anything.
I was just happy to do it,
because I loved the series
and was fascinated by it.
And I got to talk to a
lot of the folks involved.
After anything I've done in the business
for the last 20 years,
nothing compared to the response of that.
(laughs)
I've never been a part
of anything that was that popular, ever.
Combine "The Soup" and
"Community," not even close
to one 40-minute special
- Oh, my God.
- of me going, "How's Oklahoma?"
So that's basically--
(laughs)
- Well Octavia, what have
you been binge-watching?
- I've been watching "Little Fires."
- I haven't seen that!
I wanna see that, is that so good?
- Oh, so good, so good.
I'm not kidding you, I'm
going back to simpler times.
I'm watchin' "The Waltons."
- Wow.
- I love it.
- And "Little House on the Prairie,"
things before times of Corona.
- You're in a dark place if
you're needing that kind.
You're like, all of a sudden--
- I need it, I need it.
I need Pa.
Ma, Pa, Half Pint.
- You're goin' way back.
- I need it.
- You're like, "I need nostalgia
"from whenever I could go
ride my bike and be outside."
- I like how, "I'm going
back before Corona."
I was like, "You could've done ER."
(laughs)
I mean, that was 25 years ago.
But you decided to go back
- ER?
- almost 40 years ago.
50 years ago.
- Way more.